[Music]
welcome back loose skin is a problem for
many of us but we now have a
non-invasive solution
here is lisa brooks from the jazzy
wellness to tell us more
hey lisa how are you good how are you
great so tell us what is an
ultrasound skin lift ultra scout
ultrasound skin lift actually is
well let's start out it's a hundred
percent um non-invasive
and it's fda approved and
it goes it's ultrasound that
is heat and it goes down and focuses in
on your collagen and elastin and it can
be done on your eyebrows it could be
done in your face
it could be done on your decollete your
neck it could be done anywhere on your
body
and so how long how long does a
treatment take someone comes in let's
say they want to have their face done
their neck done that turkey neck how
long does it take
it takes about an hour or so um
you're in and you lay down and relax and
we're done in about an hour
we're looking at these these are
same-day results we're seeing right now
on the screen this is
unbelievable how long do these results
last
these results can last up to five to six
years wow
um it's actually what it's doing is when
we're regenerating that collagen we're
actually
slowing down the aging process so how
does it compare to other procedures i
know
the big thing this is non-invasive but
how does it compare to other procedures
out there
well other procedures like i said this
is non-invasive but other procedures use
lasers we don't use the lasers with this
treatment it's a
focused ultrasound so that's what makes
it different it
dives deep down into the muscle and into
the dermis and onto the skin's surface
to get all of that collagen to
regenerate rejuvenate itself
and to pull and tighten all of your skin
we're looking at the before and after
of someone's arms right there how long
does that treatment on your arms take
that is six treatments once a week and
what does it feel like what does the
actual
treatment feel like um it feels like
little
tingly feelings it's not
painful at all and so every week you
guys have a special for us lisa and
actually i'll hit the special for us
lisa thank you so much for joining us we
truly appreciate it
the jazzy wellness they're located at
900 south valley view
suite 100 you can find them online at
thejazzywellness.com
take advantage here's the special deal
the first 10 callers
receive 40 off the non-surgical facelift
and las vegas now will be right